hello
and welcome to the
our two-hour segment uh the
grandmaster's choice
and games of the week so for the choice
i kind of went back and forth about
different
options i really wanted to look at um
some of the puzzles but at the same time
i really wanted to go
and show some games of queen sacrificing
but
i kind of landed on
puzzles because it's always such a good
warm up for the brain
and these are some of the puzzles that
they're not just like
easy tactics they're very you actually
have to think about them a lot you have
to be able to
um make that decision on well what is
going on in the position you can't
just be like okay i want to take this
it's a good it's a
very great mix of tactics and strategy
so i really do like that um
and for our next hour i
am hoping to be able to um
look at some of the games that
were played in the birthing championship
which ended a few days ago
uh and because they were also very great
and adam's won it and i'm a huge fan
he's such a great person just
he's always so calm i wish i knew how to
be
that calm so hopefully we're going to
enjoy that too i don't see
uh he's really he's just the sweetest
person
all right so let's go ahead and get
started i have the chats ready
from here i'm reading the chat
i'm looking at the um
game here i got my tea and coffee here
so it should be kind of fun so let's
just keep going
um here it is why to move
how do you think white should play
and keep in mind that i gave you a heads
up that it doesn't necessarily have to
be some crazy tactic
so
you can you can try to take a step back
and start
analyzing by just basically
what is going on and who is better
just evaluate the position a little bit
yeah i realized i've been drinking a
little too much tea and coffee and i
probably need
to switch to water
yeah also realize i ate like two
corns on cup today and i don't think
that's healthy i think i should
slow down on my corn intake
so i see a lot of interesting b4s and
h5s and stuff like that
but i think so if it's black to move
what do you think black is going to do
i like the ideas that you're suggesting
but i think you got to do something
first and then
do the ideas that you're sharing
yeah exactly fisher you are
awesome yeah you should go for this idea
with bishop b3 just because
you are attacking over here and you can
also still keep h5 in the back of your
mind
so what do you think black should do
after bishop e3
hello oscar
i like dorsal's choice should probably
be peachy's choice but if it was his
twist it will be sniffing tuna at the
moment
speaking of tuna you should probably
order something
i'm kidding i'm not the biggest fan of
tuna it's good but
it's the same food that my cat hits
yeah h6 should happen right because h5
is coming up
then you can just play h5 and just eat
this pawn easy peasy
because if you were to play something
like knight e7 now h5
and your bishop isn't real pickle now
you can just move this knight
anywhere basically d4 or g5 and you're
now threatening f3
so this is pretty cool um
let's move on i do plan to share this
link with you at the end
i have prepared like 50 puzzles to go
through i'm hoping we can knock them all
down
if not um i will use some of them
later as well but i will share this link
with you and sorry this one is black to
move
would be a little too cool if it was
white to move
what's up chess king jess king please
remind me are you the one
um are you the one who was also
in the camps or well today or earlier
like last year over the fall or am i
am i confusing you with someone
all right so i see a bunch of stuff
being taken on a d4 that that's a good
idea
queen e5 interesting keep in mind what
is i think queen e5
is what you should watch out for the
main question is
uh basically does queen e5 work because
if the answer
is no then yes you should be thinking
about something like rook takes d4
all right so i've seen few people
thinking that queen h4 does work
all right so maybe let's keep our focus
on that
so
okay so i see well the problem is peter
if you were to take queen e5 takes check
there is this queen f1 that stops it so
that's why this doesn't work
and that's why you should be a little
bit more careful with queen e5 and
that's why that
rook d4 actually does work now i think
for rook d4
you should uh think about stuff
happening on h7s where anything that
worries you on h7 square
i'm not saying it should i'm just saying
i'm just asking if there's something
that would worry you
all right well okay i think everybody
is good i see a lot of no's or god um
so yeah exactly this bishop here
protects everything
so um if you were to give check i just
played king of eight
and you don't really have another one
yeah you're kind of calling it today
that doesn't really work uh none of your
other checks
are worth considering so yeah
good what about
this one why to move
i mean he's pretty strong i wouldn't be
surprised if
i'm kidding but he's pretty strong
uh let's see i wish i could somehow um
readjust this so i could actually
um enjoy a little bit
more
c
uh also as a general rule if i don't
flip the board
and it is white to move if i flip the
board and if a1 is h8 then it is black
to move
just to avoid future confusions
i think queen f8 is definitely a cool
idea
another cool idea is actually queen c2
because you kind of um
well i mean puts like more pressure over
here
and next you could simply want to
um actually what would be my next move
just push over here
if you play f3 i play g3 and i'll just
want to push over here
that's that's certainly doable because
then
this trick is still kind of pinned over
here because if you move it i'll take on
g7
so that's that's another way of doing it
but queen f8 is strongest
now queen effect would have broke g3
because
um can you take it
because i think with queen f8 so that is
the only thing that you could worry
about potentially
hmm
well we that's the thing we can't just
go ahead and take it
because we would get mating too remove
this king
and just put kaboom so you can't just do
this
but yes rook g7 is the way to go and
that was kind of the
idea but now what to do see chess king i
think that's where
you and most of the other uh players are
little
still on the fence because you shouldn't
just take it
you still have advantage but it's very
little and
extremely hard to actually win this so
that's why you should simply go for take
and check this is the key move that i am
assuming a lot of people forgot about
yep if rook g6
now you get oh not that now you get to
take it and then play queen e5 and pick
this guy up
yeah any questions on this one
all right let's go ahead and look at
this one black to move
if there are questions just make sure to
just let me know and i can always come
back
and we can always go over deeper
oh the chat a little quiet all right i
see some ideas with queen c3 i see
someone did with queen b2
what is the idea with queen b2 because
careful because your rook on c8
is under attack oh sorry can white
castle
yes if you played something like rook d8
white could simply castle sorry i missed
that question
the problem with queen b2 is take over
here
or simply castle and
black is doing a little um unfortunate
so if you go queen c3 king has to go to
f1
then what do you do
i think that's kind of the main question
yep i see everybody seeing it good job
you guys
check and then queen d2 is the main one
because if you were to take it
now you can't really stop both of these
problems
and if you were to simply move your king
just rook c1 and d1 is unstoppable
well technically you could play king d3
if queen
didn't take it but this is still much
better for black
so yeah queen d2 was the key move if
chain g2
now you can even play roxy one that's
how cool it is because now if you take
it
check and mate right yeah
so i think this was actually a
particularly cool one
what about this one black
if there are ever any questions just let
me know and we can always go back
otherwise i think this is a good brain
warm-up
and by the way i forgot to mention this
gmp she is asleep right up on his throne
he did make few
um appearances on our
um on our twitch channel
but yeah he's been a little too cute
recently
yeah i just i really don't know what to
do but it's just super
cute not that i'm complaining
but
all right so i see a lot of nice
candidate moves on taking on a2
rook takes d3 i think those are all
definitely worth it let's see what chess
king is suggesting
because uh you know you guys don't have
a sucker for lines
rook takes d3 or takes c3 we take that
everything gets
exchanged there and there's a queen b2
checkmate interesting so if rookie 332
there's a queen b2
okay so i i can live with that what
about rectitude reductive rig
3 queen take c3
so after one pair of rook are exchanged
what if
queen takes c3 okay you're talking about
rook takes okay
um rook takes d1 queen probably will go
to c1
and then what
i'm just kind of testing your chest
because i'm pretty sure you guys i mean
when i'm pretty sure when i talk about
it
you are following me but i would still
kind of want to
kind of check it a little
all right
all right yeah you guys got this so we
should take it over here
take take take we take on d1 and after
take just take and it's becoming a queen
easy peasy nice job chess king and much
of everybody
thinking about it there were some other
suggestions for example with queen c4
the problem is that it's not that it's
wrong it's that you give your opponent
too many chances and you also lose this
pawn
which you shouldn't you shouldn't lose
the strong pawn
so that's something that you should
avoid uh the other thing
is the queen d4 was also pretty
interesting because
you're still kind of holding all these
cool ideas but
um like if take you still have like rook
b8 and then
b7 and everything going on b3 so you
should
this is still pretty doable but i would
still recommend
the the most clear one which is
taking on d3 and if you were to take
over here then i could just
take it and then b2
i think b2 is the easiest way to win
what about taking first
um the problem is king takes if queen
takes yeah but
king takes and you don't really have any
checks
that's kind of my issue
yeah if there was no king take then i
would definitely go for it
but now you don't really have checks i
mean yeah if you move your queen then
king a3 also becomes doable
uh it's just too much giving opportunity
to the opponent
yeah careful your queen is under attack
right now
all right so let me move on to the next
one
this one is white to move this one
shouldn't be too hard
you
i see a lot of rook f6 stroke h7 ideas
um
fisher where are you at okay ricky
so i'll tell you a little secret and
the first one to solve it would be
named crown by crowned by peachy
it's made in six moves
so if you can give me all six moves i'm
sure
i can get peachy to crown you the king
oh super cute
so i think ever i mean you all have the
first move but
it's the rest of it so take take uh
rook f6 track king james what rook h7
i'm assuming you're going with king
seven error capsicum six check knee
seven
um it's not trick e6
elvis i'm reading it reverse seven is
made but
after king g7 i i don't think um
i don't think i've seen the right ideas
so far
on the third one third move
yeah g6 you guys got this now okay
great so take take check king moves now
rock g6 is the key move
and then you go again to g7 because
now well it's double check and your
queen is defending it so you just kind
of like deleted the f6 pawn so you could
go to g7
you guys got this king h6 and now you
got maintain two yep
um
well to be fair i guess if the king did
go to f8
that is also you are correct this is
checkmate
you're correct um but if king goes to h7
rook g7 is the way to go
king h6 throw in that lovely check
uh take and then checkmates
all right um what is wrong with rick h7
okay
take okay so here you want to play queen
f3 it is doable
this is still made but it's just not the
fastest mate
this is still very much winning um
you just have to be careful because here
rg8 exists you're just gonna have to
make sure to see rook g8 or rook h6
actually
no i'm actually coin f3 works so never
mind
yeah queen f3 works just as well just
not as fast
all right
okay let's move on to the next one and i
gotta have some tea
oh so i found this amazing teas
i mean i i used to have them when i was
in
russia a lot and um so if you have any
russian ukrainian azerbaijani friends in
the chat
i'm sure you guys will know what i'm
talking about they're called greenfield
and i found my mom really likes the
lemon one
uh they're black tea but they're
actually very tasty
i really enjoy the um
the spring melody one
so they're actually very good i think
i'll get like a tea
um tea plates t
i don't know how to say like a mix of
different teas to see which ones are
better
but so far i'm i'm a huge fan of this
one
let's see
okay so fisher has the right idea
oh hello from italia too sorry i was
still thinking about teaspoon
uh taking is a good idea because take if
the king
takes then knight f4 yeah queen d2
possible
um i think that bishop like
understanding bishop takes
e7 is kind of the hardest one
because you can easily see that white
has special advantage
but black's um main hope is to get this
knight f5
so in order to stop that it's a good
choice to take
take and i would bet my
chest knowledge that this is a french
position so
take take and then knight goes to g5
putting more pressure over here you
don't exactly you might not exactly want
to take it but you're questioning now
where did rook should go
if rick goes to g7 now do you guys see
any cool tactics or anything
uh always generally when i don't flip
the board
it is white it is white too if i flip
the board and it's black to move
um
anybody see anything cool
to be fair there is not just one way to
win
but yeah take on f7 if you guys got this
take and then you take over here
still going after e6 as well um
and now if rook goes to f8
check king moves away take over here
check
check because the king can't go to d8
because we will have this cool fork
so the king is just kind of busted has
to stay here until we finally push it
and now how do we win
all right i see some interesting ideas
but
i think queen d5 is just the easiest way
to win knight f7
uh knight f7 is also doable but the king
gets to run a little bit
so let's just go out for the one that
we're sure about queen d5 because knight
d6 coming up even if you move the king
now i can just go knight t6 again going
after these two big stuff
i agree fisher it's a little humiliating
with the queen d5
now you can just take it over here and
simply play e6 and that's also coming up
the fun thing is your key seven can't
even work because
you would simply have either queen a8 or
queen f5
so it's just like five pawns to one
night so
it's really amazing so i think this is
so far my favorite one
just because of how many pawns there is
any questions on this or should we go
ahead and move
all right i'm going to go ahead and move
if there are any questions just let me
know we can always come back
what about here black tube uh white too
sorry not like to move
i have to say i do miss holding a live
class though
i'm gonna miss that interaction
all right so i see a lot of ideas and
i'd have to say i definitely love
how you guys gonna answer each other
that is kind of my purpose in the chat
too
that's why i give you the time so you
guys can kind of like um
bounce ideas off of each other i think
that's that's something that everyone
should do
so
oh wait exquisite oh i wish i i
i'm well i well i'm a little stunned
because i didn't thank anybody from my
class was watching that's so great i'm
i'm so glad you watch
all right so i'm going to go ahead and
answer some questions in the chat
so rook e6 seems to be the most favorite
one
and yes as stated i think fisher
and other people you should definitely
think about bishop d4
because that's a check and you should
think about it and
well if this check you could definitely
take it
if queen takes e6 now i'm gonna
uh keep in mind the problem with rook d5
is this queen e1
and then trying to give you perpetual
so you should not go for that
so you shouldn't take rook d5 and you
know that white black wants to play this
check and give you another check and
then come back give you another check
so how can you stop it
i see everybody had talked about this
idea of
rookie four
ah sorry rook d5 but sorry i was reading
chess king's um
rookie four yeah rookie four is the way
to go that's actually the only way to
win
and i think this tactic is a little
too cool because now like there's a
stroke d1 and a king goes to h2
and um you're attacking over here and
also going after that
so if queen g6 now you would again have
like check pick this up
if it goes to d5 you would have rookie
five but that's like
it's a very good advantage but to be
fair you had something a little bit
easier here
queen takes d4 is the easier way to go
because now if take i just take that
with check and i haven't i have an extra
piece
so i think that's what you should have
gone for
instead of taking with the rook taking
with the rook is also
very advantageous but it kind of gives
your opponents that chance
so in order to stop that you would have
to find the only move of rookie 4.
and generally only moves are a little
hard to find so we don't want to do that
all right so let's move on to a little
bit of
end game a little bit
you know i always wanted to start a
class with
having to actually time it correctly and
do
openings middle games and games but
it just never really happens like this
just kind of we kind of get lost into
the middle game of it
so it is y2
i see the idea of g4 g4 does not win
because g for king g6 and the king
get the e6 fast
ah
it's also kind of funny squares and
chats are not
kind of unrealistic
so one two three four bunch of fours
has it right yeah you gotta go bishop g3
i'll tell you why g4 doesn't work so
ideally g4 would work but the problem is
king g6 now you bring your bishop
king goes to f7 if you bring your bishop
take stakes and stop it
and all you're gonna get out of this
game is a draw push
take if you push now the king actually
stops then you lose
you bring the king first now upon pawn
marks and this is going to be a draw
so let's go back um over
here g4 another reason why
it doesn't exactly work is that you
don't i mean even if you play this g5
then still king can just go to g6 or
king king
sorry bishop can just take it over here
and the king is way too close
so that's why you should go bishop g3
first now if king moves now you have
bishop h4
because if take now you just take and
then he can't really stop you
oops because it's too far right
and if he doesn't take on bishop c7 now
you make a queen
take take and you're going to pick one
of these pawns up and your bishop will
stay over here and that pawn becomes a
queen this is winnable
now what if a4 starts to push this
whoops
starts to push this one now what
all right so i see i think everybody is
good you guys got this just have to go
for the special h4
um and
if take you still know what to do if
we'll
take that's why you would play g4 now
you're kind of holding a g4
and if the king moves now you can simply
take it and the king is too far away to
reach
and if not if bishop c7 you would still
now question can you still push and give
that
um or not
or should you do something first
well see the problem is if you were to
do this first
it still works but it's not as exciting
because king goes to g6
maybe tries to stop it over here then
you have to take here i mean it still
works perfectly
but it's a little more intriguing whoops
if bishop c7 you maybe give this check
first king moves and then you make a
queen
just to just to you know like torture
them a little bit
and if b5 now just bishop e7 and you
stop it all
i kind of like this idea of g4 giving
check but it's fine it's perfectly fine
both of them work
just equally just make sure you do this
bishop g3
first all right let's continue
with these white to move
so
oh all right i think you guys are seeing
it but i'm kind of hoping for a little
bit more detail
because i see that you guys are
definitely thinking about knight h5
circuit sevens
taking on g6 so you all have like the
right mix of ideas
but not exact move order
so i'm kind of hoping for that just a
little bit
okay so to be fair um
knight taking on g6 works just as well
after take uh you take it over here
the thing is you can't really take it
because queen h5 and then
checkmate whoops sorry checkmate
so that's why after take over here you
would do something like queen f6
and then you could either take it over
there or try to
come back here go on h5 both of them
perfectly fine
um maybe now you could just you know
kind of thinking um per h7 is up or
just pulling rookies one and just bring
more pressure
but this gives your opponent too much
chance so that's why you should look for
something a little bit more forceful
now what do you think that forceful move
is
yeah brick h7 after rick takes h7
if you were to take with the king now i
take over here with my knight
and next i want to go queen h5 so you
have to try and
well also i want to take over here so
you have to try and move this queen and
you can't really go over here to stop it
because i'll just pick up your
your rook and i'm much better um
and if you were to play like queen
before attacking a little over here
how did we win
nice elvis yeah
we can just take it over here to be
honest and
if king moves just bring it over check
and this is just perfectly fine your
king is super weak you have a bunch of
extra pawns
and even if you want to exchange queen
sure why not
you move your knights just take it over
here
yeah i think these are the easiest ways
to win actually
um all right let's do one more to be
fair
let me also point this out here q5 is
also doable
but it's not as forceful and it kind of
gives black a little chance to you know
make some stuff happen so that's why i
wouldn't exactly recommend it
all right what about this one
and this one is actually black to move
can you survive this
well it's important to see how you would
bring this check
well you could do queenish one you could
do queen f1 but queen swan
what if king goes to g4 then what would
you do
yeah so the thing is queen of swan
if king goes to g3 i agree we'll just
check check check it up
because you can't really go to f4
because i'll just have queen h2 and
i won't be needing much more chicks
after that so
what if king goes to g4 that's kind of
our problem because queen g2 doesn't
work there's queen g3
yeah you kind of are running out of
checks unless you find the right check
knight e5 you guys got this good good
knight t5 is the perfect idea
because now if you were to take it now i
have this
awesome sacrifice and voila
still mates it's been a while since we
did some stalemate so i'm glad you're
doing it still mate
um yeah i think this is a perfectly cool
idea
because if you don't take it and if you
well move your king
now it's gonna be checkmate right and if
you
take it to the queen i would just take
that back and that's another easy peasy
game
so yeah this kind of should teach you to
watch out for checkmates
and with that i am going to end this
stream
and take a quick break refill on my
coffee
or tea probably shouldn't do both though
and i'll be back in about
eight or eight minutes or so so we can
go and look at some of the british
championship games
until then please feel free to hang
around i will send you the link for this
actually um ben if you could please take
care of sending a link
it is on leachate studies
um personal studies well it's actually
not locked too
uh even if this doesn't work i can
always share the link on the next
um on our next lesson but feel free to
just go to sendless just go
look at the studies and find us we did
about
10 or 12 first chapters so it should be
fun
oh from iceland also i actually did not
know you were in iceland
so i will see you all in a little bit
have fun
and for those of you going to sleep have
a good night and make sure to check the
video tomorrow